so someone made a comment on one of my youtube
videos recently and they said my grandfather ate
bread sugar and drank alcohol whiskey his entire
life even smoked and he lived to be over 90 years
old so how do you explain that dr berg i thought
that if we consume these foods we're supposed
to die early well here's the thing everyone
comes into this world with a different package
different genes different family histories
so if you had several generations before you
that really took care of their bodies they
ate healthy consume food from fertile land
you're going to probably end up with some pretty
robust genes because there wasn't a lot of
things to weaken those genetics so you probably
could then be the person who gets away with it
there are certain countries that have perfect
bone structure and teeth like in africa they live
off food that is grown on volcanic soil so you
get all these amazing trace minerals that build
really healthy bone structure then you have
other countries that produce different types of
foods that you end up with a lot of teeth decay
like in the uk there's a tremendous amount of
sugar refined foods and and dental issues same
thing with the us so depending on your genetics
your family history the foods the country that you
live in it can make a huge difference of where you
are on the spectrum but the great majority of
people unfortunately develop metabolic diseases
earlier and earlier but there's usually a point in
someone's life a time that things start to break
down for me it was 28 years old you see before
that i could eat bread and i ate a ton of bread a
ton of sugar and i definitely drank alcohol and i
had absolutely no symptoms whatsoever i felt great
so i can get away with it and that's why i had no
attention on it i didn't want to change because
i felt fine at that point in my life you couldn't
educate me about keto or cutting off carbs because
i didn't i wasn't fat i felt great i had
no problems until 28 years old and then i
started to really start to go downhill and that's
when i started to make some changes so there are
several factors that would determine if this is 28
years old or earlier or a lot later that would be
your genetics how robust your genes are from
your family tree then you have epigenetics the
environment what happens in the environment your
eating habits your stress level pollution there
are a lot of factors that are epigenetic factors
which are basically even above the genetics what
happened with me when i was 28 is i went through
tremendous stress right before that going through
school and and starting out in practice and i know
that did not help compounded by the fact that i
was eating completely refined empty calories
without any type of vegetables whatsoever or
anything nutrient dense and then you have your
health reserve how much reserve do you have
and then your attitude which is
another factor which is very very very
important probably should be at the top of the
list you have some people that are so positive
they're so up that they never get sick so
this is a really important factor as well
all right there you have it that's my response to
this question before you go if you have a question
about a product or you're new to keto and you want
to know how to begin keto or you're on keto and
you need a debug because it's not going as smooth
i have a keto consultant standing by to help you
this is just for the people in the us hopefully in
the future we'll be able to answer everyone's call
but i put the number down below
so you can call and get some help